so my mum is lovely and I am going to
tell me why now this is video that I
posted ages and ages and ages ago where
I asked people to submit challenges for
me to do in my videos and the other day
my mum went through those comments and
picked out her favorite challenges and
she told me the usernames and everything
and this isn't something that I asked
her to do she just did it because she's
really really nice one of the challenges
that she suggested I could do was buy
frozen undies
I like that username see how many
marshmallows you can fit in your mouth
which is what I did about 10 minutes ago
I Charlie McDonnell can fit 30
marshmallows in my mouth I am very proud
of this and I'm going to show you a
video of me doing it but before I show
it to you I would like to say it's
becoming apparent to me that I'm being
known as the guy who does crazy stupid
things on the internet you know paying
myself purple drinking ketchup shoving
loads of marshmallows in my mouth now
and I would just like to say I have no
problem being known as the crazy guy on
YouTube here again is me doing something
really really stupid just to make you
laugh I just wanted to comment on the
fact that for some reason I went from
having no tan at all to looking like I
just spent three weeks in Spain I don't
know how this happened but can we just
please focus on the important things
I like watching me put marshmallows in
my mouth thank you actually you've mini
marshmallows they're all going in my
cheeks to start off with all that at
some point oh I uh ha ha
I was actually just sick in the sink
just then there's now a clump of
marshmallows in my sink all covered in
stick hey you go 13 sick colored
marshmallows and right back to having no
tan at all I just showed that video to
my mum and she really liked it but she
said maybe put a bit of a warning in
please don't try doing that at home it's
pretty obvious that you're just gonna
make yourself sick it's not worth making
a video response for I do these things
so that you don't have to I can be an
idiot you can be smart and learn from my
mistakes I am never gonna do that again
so that is my warning don't try this at
home kids that's all I have to say bye
yeah you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool